La militante de la paix
que je suis-je le dis aussi avec force,
ne faisons pas n'importe quoi.
Les armements
produits ne peuvent servir à de salle guerre.
Je pense à celle mener au Yémen
où la France
est en pointe pour son aide à l'Arabie Saoudite
avec de nombreux crimes de guerre à la clé.
Hâte ! Je dis à la logique d'escalade,
non à l'autant
et non à l'autant en Ukraine,
non aussi à l'envoi d'arme en Israël.
La France n'exporterait pas seulement
des composants défensifs
pour le tome de fer, mais aussi
des pièces
permettant le fonctionnement des fusils mitrailleurs
susceptible
d'avoir été utilisé contre les civils palestinaux.